اوقفت وزاره الموارد البشريه والتنميه
الاجتماعيه صرف معاشات الضمان الاجتماعي
لاكثر من 7300 مستفيد في دفعه الشهر
الماضي لاخلالهم بشرط من شروط صرف المعاش
وكشفت مصادر العربيه عن حصول جميع
المستفيدين من الضمان الاجتماعي الذين
اوقفت الوزاره مع شاهين بسبب ثبوت عدم
جديتهم في البحث عن عمل على ثلاثه فرص عمل
متنوعه رفضوها وفتحت الوزاره باب الاعتراض
لمده شهر ولم يتقدم احد منهم باي اعتراض
انضم الينا هاتفيا من الرياض الدكتور حمد
الحماده الوكيل مساعد لسياسات والتشريعات
في وكاله الضمان الاجتماعي والتمكين حياك
الله دكتور حمد معي في نشره الرابعه اولا
من تفاصيل اضافيه لهذا القرار
حياك الله مرحب فيك اخوي خالد وفي الساده
المشاهدين
واجابه على سؤالك فان من اهم اهداف الضمان
الاجتماعي في المملكه تمكين المستفيدين من
تحقيق الاستقلال المالي والتحول الى شخص
منتج من خلال التاهيل والتدريب وفقا لمنصه
على ذلك الماده الثانيه من نظام الضمان
الاجتماعي الصاد من سوى الملكي رقم ميم
على 32
لعام 1442 ولذلك تعمل الوزاره تنفيذه
للمعامل المنوطه بها على التعاون مع صندوق
تنميه الموارد البشريه هدف والجهاز ذات
العلاقه في اعداد خطه لكل مستفيد قابل
للتاهيل وقادر على العمل وتقديم خدمات
البحث عن العمل كذلك المتابعه المستمره
للمستفيدين القادرين على العمل للتحقق من
مدى تاهيلهم وايضا مدى جديه القادر على
العمل في البحث عن العمل وقبوله لعروض
العمل والتدريب المناسب وبناء على ذلك
قامت الوزاره بتقديم خطط وفرص عمل مناسبه
لعدد كبير من المستفيدين الضمان الاجتماعي
استفاد منها عدد كبير منهم تجاوز عدد
الممكنين في العام الماضي وحده مئه الف
مستفيد الا ان عدد من المستفيدين القادرين
على العمل او القابلين للتاهيل ومن تم وضع
خطه لتمكينهم لم يلتزم
[موسيقى]
الفقره الرابعه والخامسه من الماده
السابعه عشر النظام الضمان الاجتماعي ان
يتوقف المعاش متى تبت ان المستفيد القادر
على العمل او القابل للتاهيل لم
يلفت العمل والتدريب المقدمه لهم كيف
تثبتم في الوزاره دكتور حمد يعني العدد
7300 شخص يعني عدد مو بسيط
بعد قيام المستفيد بالتسجيل في المنصه
واستحقاقه للمعاش تبدا الوزاره بتقنيه
المستفيدين بناء البيانات والمعلومات
المتعلقه بحاله المستفيد الصحيه مثل
البدنيه ايضا كذلك والاجتماعيه على النحو
التالي مستفيد قادر للقادر على العمل
ومستفيد قابل للتاهيل ومستفيد غير قابل
للتاهيل ونقصد بغير القابل للتاهيل هي
الحالات التي لا يمكن ان تمارس اي من
الاعمال التي تساهم في تحويل المستفيد الى
شخص منتج ومستقل ماليا مثل كبار السن او
المعاصر اعاقه جعلت من شخص غير قادر على
العمل وبعد ذلك ولتحقيق اهداف الضمان
الاجتماعي يطلب من المست
فيد قادر على العمل او القابل للت
اهيل
وعند عدم ثبوت جديه المستفيد في الالتزام
بالخطه حينها يتم ايقاف صرف المعاش له
تنفيذا للفقره الرابعه والخامسه من الماده
السابعه عشر من نظام الضمان الاجتماعي
والوزاره تتحقق من ثبوت عدم جديه البحث عن
العمل وفق لما يرد اليها من صندوق تنه
التنميه البشريه هدف بناء الاجراءات
والسياسات المقرره هناك مثل عدم تسجيل
المستفيدين في منصه الموحده للتوظيف
والموافقه عليها والاقرار على الالتزامات
الوارده فيها وبالمناسبه جميع من تم ايقاف
الصوت عنهم هم من اخلوا بهذا الفقره فلم
يقوموا بالتسجيل في المنصه الموحده
للتوظيف
والاسياسات الوارده لدى صندوق التنميه
البشريه
هذا التجاوب والتواصل مع التنميه البشريه
اكثر من
ثلاث مرات او التخلف عن حضور المقابل
الوظيفيه اللي ثلاث مرات او عدم قبول
الفرص الوظيفيه المعروضه للمستفيد لمده
ثلاث مرات بس يمكن فرص المقدمه اصلا او
الموجوده
وما تلائم ظروف وربما حين في هذه الحاله
الاجراءات التي تقومون فيها يعني
التاهيل من اشخاص متلقين الدعم الاجتماعي
الى افراد منتجين ومستقلين ماليين عبر
خدمات التاهيل والتمكين لان الاصل في
القاده الامل هو ان يعمل ولذلك تقدم
الوزاره للمستفيدين ما يتوفر للقطاع الخاص
تناسب مؤهلات كل مستفيد على حده وتجدر
الاشاره الى ان المتطلبات من المستفيدين
تكون على حالته الحاله الاولى اثبات
الجديه في البحث عن العمل وذلك مثل قيامه
بالتسجيل في غرفه صندوق كلمه الموارد
البشريه طاقات
في
[موسيقى]
قبول الخلايا شركائها بعد قيام الوزاره
بدراسه المؤهلات المستفيدين
ومطابقتها ومعرفه مدى مناسبه هذه الفرص
البيئه اعتذارات تقبلها الوزاره علما بان
الوزاره تقدم ثلاث فرص وظيفيه لهؤلاء
المستفيدين وتتحرر الوزاره ان تكون هذه
الثلاث فرص الوظ
يفيه لها مناسبه مع هذا
النقطه هنا مهمه وهي ان الفرص الوظيفيه
لتقدمها الوزاره للمستشهدين هي اعلى من
الحد الادنى للاجور وبالتالي فهي بطبيعه
الحال اعلى من مبلغ الدعم المقدم للمستفيد
في الضمان الاج